rien n'arrête le tvb en quart de finale
aller de la coupe s'est achevé hier soir
à grenon les volleyeurs tourangeaux ont
mangé les tchèques victoire 3 sets à 0
contre carlo vasco dans un match que
vous avez pu suivre en direct sur votre
chaîne les hommes de marcello
fronckowiak est désormais à 2,7 des demi
finales romain des deux villes le tours
volley ball dans les meilleures
dispositions dans son quart de finale
contre l'équipe tchèque de carlo vasco
une victoire 3 sets à 0 25-22 27-25 et
25 22 un match aller plus serré que n'en
laisse penser le score c'est pourquoi à
la fin du match les esprits étaient déjà
tournés vers le match retour
[Musique]
un peu plus
à la fin techniquement il faut que ce
faucon soir au manioc le tour pour y
réaliser première manche les tourangeaux
font le break d'entrée à 5 0 les
tchèques court après le score mais ne le
rattrape jamais deuxième set là les deux
équipes sont au coude à coude les trois
quarts du temps les un homme va
débloquer la situation côté tvb pierre
de rouillon 22 ans bras gauche en feu
hier soir dans le dernier set le tvb
fait la différence à 10 partout
maintient son avance et déroule
s'envoler jusqu'à la victoire
le plus dur c'est là bas qu'on gagne ou
qu'on perde ici le plus dur c'est
matches à l'extérieur donc là va falloir
redoubler de vigilance d'abord on a
juste assuré ce soir le travail comme de
faire
va falloir beaucoup travailler parce que
ils vont nous attendre encore plus au
match chez eux des tours on joue on
monte un pied en demi finale de la coupe
d'europe s'est levé reste à valider le
ticket jeudi prochain à carlo vasco pour
cela il faudra gagner au moins deux sets
en république tchèque